It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. It's one of memory's strangest tricks. You're visiting a new city, one you've never been to before, when you turn a corner, and suddenly you get the overwhelming sense you've been there before. You can't shake the feeling even though your rational mind knows that it can't be true. That fleeting, eerie sensation, deja vu, has puzzled psychologists for more than a century. Now researchers are learning more about the causes of deja vu, as well as its lesser-known opposite, Ja'A-Mé-Vu,
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。这是记忆最奇怪的把戏之一。你正在游览一个从未去过的新城市，当你转过一个街角，突然产生了一种强烈的似曾相识感。尽管你的理性思维知道这不可能，但你却无法摆脱这种感觉。这种转瞬即逝、令人毛骨悚然的感觉——既视感（deja vu），一个多世纪以来一直困扰着心理学家。现在，研究人员正在深入了解既视感的成因，以及它鲜为人知的对立面——“未视感”（Jamais vu），
when a previously known thing seems suddenly strange and unfamiliar. So why do Deja-Vu and Ja-Mé-Vu happen? Why does our brain play these tricks on us? Are some people more prone to Deja-Vo and Ja-Mé-Vu than others? How do you study these sensations in the lab? And what can studying them teach us about memory more broadly? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
即当一个已知的事物突然显得陌生和不熟悉。那么，为什么会发生既视感和未视感呢？为什么我们的大脑会跟我们玩这些把戏？有些人是否比其他人更容易产生既视感和未视感？你如何在实验室中研究这些感觉？研究它们又能让我们对记忆有更广泛的了解吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Chris Moulin, a professor in the Laboratory of Psychology and Neurocognition at Grenoble Alps University in France. He is a cognitive neuropsychologist known for his work on memory, especially Deja Vu and Ja Mevo. He's the author of hundreds of scientific studies, as well as the book, The Cognitive Geelong, Neuropsychology of DejaVu. And finally, his work on Jaumevue won a 2023 Ig Nobel Prize, an annual award given for scientific research that makes people laugh and then makes them think. Dr. Moulin, thank you for joining me today. Thank you very much for having me. We're going to talk about both DejaVu and JaMévue and some related phenomena, but let's start with
我是 Kim Mills。今天的嘉宾是法国格勒诺布尔阿尔卑斯大学心理学与神经认知实验室的教授 Chris Moulin 博士。他是一位认知神经心理学家，以其在记忆领域，特别是既视感和未视感方面的研究而闻名。他撰写了数百项科学研究，并著有《既视感的认知神经心理学》（The Cognitive Neuropsychology of Déjà Vu）一书。最后，他在未视感方面的研究获得了 2023 年搞笑诺贝尔奖，这是一项授予那些让人发笑、随后引人深思的科学研究的年度奖项。Moulin 博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。我们将讨论既视感和未视感以及一些相关现象，但让我们先从
DejaVu, which I would imagine most of us have heard of. I mentioned a classic example of DejaVu in the introduction when a place you've never been before seems familiar and you have the sense that you've been there. Are there other types of deja vu or other examples of when this happens? So that is the classic example to find yourself in a place where you've never been before and feel like you've been there before. So we know that there's a kind of sense of place involved in in deja vu, but it's not the only kind. The people who fill in my questionnaires tell me that it often arrives in conversations, a conversation you might be having at a party
既视感开始，我想我们大多数人都听说过。我在介绍中提到了既视感的一个经典例子，即当你身处一个从未去过的地方时，却感到熟悉，并有一种你曾经去过那里的感觉。还有其他类型的既视感或发生这种情况的其他例子吗？是的，这就是发现自己身处一个从未去过的地方却感觉曾经去过那里的经典例子。所以我们知道既视感中包含一种空间感，但这并不是唯一的一种。填写我问卷的人告诉我，它经常出现在对话中，比如你在聚会上进行的对话
or something like that, and you'll have the sensation that you've had the same conversation before. So we think it happens for pretty much most of the things that you can be conscious of and you can think about, but certainly right up there is places. We seem to have it more for places than for other things. Interestingly, one of the straight
或者类似的事情，你会有一种感觉，觉得你之前进行过同样的对话。所以我们认为它几乎发生在你所能意识到的和思考的大多数事情上，但毫无疑问，地点是其中最突出的。我们似乎在地点上比在其他事情上更容易产生这种感觉。有趣的是，其中一个直接
The strange data sets that we have to explain is the reason why people in our questionnaires also seem to have more deja vu, the more they travel, which is a very interesting idea, especially if you think it's to do with the places you visit. It seems the more likely you are to go to novel places, the more likely you are to experience deja vu, which is a very interesting idea. So it sounds like that's one of the triggers, travel. Are there other things that may trigger deja vu? So for deja vu, one of the things we have to think about is who's having the deja vu.
我们需要解释的奇怪数据集是，为什么我们问卷中的受访者似乎旅行得越多，产生的既视感就越多，这是一个非常有趣的想法，特别是如果你认为它与你访问的地点有关的话。似乎你越有可能去新奇的地方，你就越有可能经历既视感，这是一个非常有趣的想法。所以听起来旅行是触发因素之一。还有其他可能触发既视感的事情吗？对于既视感，我们需要考虑的一点是谁在经历既视感。
So let's just talk now about healthy deja vu. And we do know that there are some triggers for healthy deja vu. That's for people like you and I who may have this rarely, and there's no kind of neurological reason why we're having deja vu. And we might have it more when we're tired. it seems that we might have it more when we're stressed. Travel is a big idea. You have it more when you're young than when you're older.
那么，现在让我们谈谈健康的既视感。我们确实知道，健康的既视感有一些触发因素。对于像你我这样可能很少有这种经历，且没有任何神经学原因导致既视感的人来说，当我们疲劳时，我们可能会更多地产生这种感觉。似乎当我们有压力时，我们也会更多地产生这种感觉。旅行是一个重要的因素。年轻人比老年人更容易产生这种感觉。
There's some research, but I think we need to do some more work on those kinds of things, which suggests that you have deja vu, not necessarily whilst you're intoxicated, but having been intoxicated with drink and drugs, for instance. So there's some. interesting data about those kinds of things. But essentially, I'm telling you about general patterns from questionnaire research, I think it's best to characterize DejaVu as being unpredictable. So we know you get it more in places than for other things, but you can get it in conversations. And I think the main thing about Dejabu is that it's unpredictable and
有一些研究，但我认为我们需要在这些方面做更多的工作，这表明你产生既视感，不一定是在你醉酒时，而是在曾经喝醉或使用药物之后，例如。所以关于这些事情有一些有趣的数据。但本质上，我是在告诉你问卷研究中的一般模式，我认为最好将既视感描述为不可预测的。所以我们知道你在地点上比在其他事情上更容易产生这种感觉，但你也可以在对话中产生这种感觉。我认为既视感最主要的一点是它是不可预测的，并且
you don't know when it's going to strike. Is there any reasons or any research behind why younger people may have it more often than older folks? So, um, The first reason that could explain this pattern of data would be that older people have deja vu the same amount, but they just forget that they've had it because it's pretty infrequent and pretty rare. So maybe they do have it as much, but they've forgotten about it. We've tried to control that by asking people about the last time they had it and asking people to remember a specific instance of it. So we think it's not that. what we think is, is this is the first piece of evidence in our idea that deja vu is a healthy thing and a good thing. So we like to describe it as a fact-checking mechanism. As you get older,
你不知道它什么时候会发生。年轻人比老年人更频繁地产生这种感觉，这背后有什么原因或研究吗？嗯，解释这种数据模式的第一个原因可能是，老年人产生既视感的频率是一样的，但他们只是忘记了自己有过这种经历，因为它非常不频繁且非常罕见。所以也许他们确实有同样多的经历，但他们忘记了。我们试图通过询问人们最后一次产生这种感觉的时间，并要求人们回忆一个具体的例子来控制这一点。所以我们认为不是这样。我们认为，这是我们认为既视感是一种健康且有益的事物这一观点的第一个证据。所以我们喜欢把它描述为一种事实核查机制。随着年龄的增长，
there's very subtle but real changes in your memory, which mean you're not quite so able to verify the certainty that something has not yet happened to you. So in my daily life, as I get older, I have far fewer experiences of deja vu, but what I have instead is a bit more that horrible hesitation. Have I already made this joke? I feel like I'm repeating myself. I feel like I probably am repeating myself. So I think as you get older, that that relationship with your memory changes, and we call that metacognition, so that you're less aware of what's going on in your memory system. And as you get older, you just lack that kind of certainty that it's impossible that you've already had this conversation or it's impossible that feeling you've
你的记忆力会发生非常微妙但真实的变化，这意味着你验证某事尚未发生在你身上的确定性能力有所下降。所以在我日常生活中，随着年龄增长，我产生既视感的经历少多了，但我取而代之的是更多那种可怕的犹豫。我开过这个玩笑了吗？我觉得我在重复自己。我觉得我可能确实在重复自己。所以我认为随着年龄增长，你与记忆的关系发生了变化，我们称之为元认知，所以你对记忆系统中发生的事情的感知力降低了。随着年龄增长，你只是缺乏那种“我不可能已经进行过这次对话”或“我不可能已经来过这里”的确定性。
already been here. More likely as you get older, you might say, well, I probably read about this place in a book or it's very similar to some other place that I've been. So your interpretation of the same feeling possibly changes as you get older. And that's probably our best case explanation for that. But already, again, a very interesting piece of data for us, because if you think that memory gets worse as you get older, you'd expect to have more deja vu if you're saying that memory is a, is behind deja vu. It's like a deja vu is a memory error. But in fact, you get the opposite. So that's really why we come to this idea of it's not quite about memory. It's about your relationship with your memory.
随着年龄增长，你更有可能说，嗯，我可能在书里读过这个地方，或者它和我去过的其他地方非常相似。所以你对同样感觉的解读可能会随着年龄增长而改变。这可能是我们对此最好的解释。但同样，这对我们来说是一个非常有趣的数据，因为如果你认为记忆力随着年龄增长而变差，你会期望如果你说记忆是既视感的背后原因，那么你会有更多的既视感。这就像既视感是一种记忆错误。但事实上，情况恰恰相反。所以这就是为什么我们得出这个观点，即它不仅仅是关于记忆。它是关于你与记忆的关系。
You've worked with patients with epilepsy and dementia who have chronic deja vu. That is, they have a constant sense that everything that's happening to them is familiar. Can you talk about that? Why does that happen? And what's life like for those patients? Yeah. So my whole entry point into researching deja vu was through looking at somebody working closely with somebody who had a permanent sense of deja vu, at least his family,
你曾与患有癫痫和痴呆症并伴有慢性既视感的患者合作过。也就是说，他们有一种持续的感觉，认为正在发生的一切都很熟悉。你能谈谈这个吗？为什么会发生这种情况？这些患者的生活是什么样的？是的。我研究既视感的整个切入点是通过密切观察一个有永久性既视感的人，至少他的家人
and his doctors all described it as a permanent set of deja vu. And I was a young neuropsychologist just out of my PhD at that time. And I looked up in a book, Deja Vu, and I thought, well, there'll be an explanation of why this person's got deja vu. And in fact, there was nothing similar. And his case was very extreme. Subsequently, we've identified other people that's the same. But for instance, when he came to the memory technique, he said there was no point doing my memory tests because he'd already done them all before. he said that every conversation was repeating, that he'd already met me when I turned up at his house to do some research with him.
和他的医生都将其描述为永久性的既视感。那时我是一名刚拿到博士学位的年轻神经心理学家。我在书里查了“既视感”，我想，肯定会有解释为什么这个人会有既视感。但事实上，并没有类似的情况。他的病例非常极端。随后，我们确定了其他人也是如此。但例如，当他进行记忆测试时，他说做我的记忆测试没有意义，因为他以前都做过了。他说每次对话都在重复，当我到他家和他一起做研究时，他说他已经见过我了。
He refused to watch television, saying that everything was repeating on the television. He was an engineer and he took, still, he had subscriptions to scientific journals. And I like this one the most. He stopped reading his scientific journals saying that he'd read everything in them already before. and sometimes an experience that us scientists have anyway in general. So his life was very, very difficult. Certainly for his wife, she was very patient and was very interested in the research and saw the kind of philosophical side of things.
他拒绝看电视，说电视上的一切都在重复。他是一名工程师，他仍然订阅科学期刊。我最喜欢这个例子。他停止阅读他的科学期刊，说他以前已经读过里面的一切了。有时这也是我们科学家普遍拥有的体验。所以他的生活非常非常困难。当然，对于他的妻子来说，她非常有耐心，对这项研究非常感兴趣，并看到了事情的哲学层面。
But it was constant torment. From the moment he woke up, he was saying that he'd already had that conversation, that he'd already done all the things and the chores that he needed to be doing at the house. So it really was more like being stuck in the present moment, more like anything like deja vu. So we did some research with him and identified memory mechanisms and brain mechanisms that were involved. And that was really interesting work and that launched my interest in deja vu.
但这是一种持续的折磨。从他醒来的那一刻起，他就说他已经进行过那次对话，他已经完成了他在家里需要做的所有事情和家务。所以这真的更像是被困在当下，而不是像既视感。所以我们对他进行了一些研究，确定了涉及的记忆机制和大脑机制。那是非常有趣的工作，它开启了我对既视感的兴趣。
But of course, it took me a bit of time to realize, but that's not actually what deja vu is when we have deja vu. When we have deja vu, we are aware that we're having a deja vu. So he was not aware that he had this kind of problem. So one of the things his wife used to ask him, it's like, okay, if you've watched this TV program before, can you tell me what's going to happen next? And his response was very can he. He used to reply, well, how should I know what happens next?
但当然，我花了一点时间才意识到，但当我们产生既视感时，那实际上并不是既视感。当我们产生既视感时，我们意识到我们正在产生既视感。所以他并没有意识到他有这种问题。所以他妻子过去常问他的一件事是，好吧，如果你以前看过这个电视节目，你能告诉我接下来会发生什么吗？他的回答非常无奈。他过去常回答，嗯，我怎么会知道接下来会发生什么？
I've got a memory problem. So he was kind of aware that he had difficulties with his memory, but he was not aware that he had this constant feeling of repetition, that his life was repeating. So again, that helps us converge on what deja vu is, because for us, deja vu is this conflict, this sense that it feels like it's familiar, but I know it's not.
我有记忆问题。所以他有点意识到他的记忆有困难，但他没有意识到他有这种持续的重复感，即他的生活在重复。所以这再次帮助我们聚焦于什么是既视感，因为对我们来说，既视感是一种冲突，一种感觉它很熟悉，但我知道它不是的感觉。
And we think with him and the other patients who are similar, all of whom have had this kind of dementia pattern and have been older adults, and it is very, very rare. They've all had this kind of permanent sense of familiarity. And instead of being able to reject the sense of familiarity as something false and erroneous, these patients actually accept it and then kind of work with it and embellish it and have details to it and so on and so forth. So there's a very interesting cases and that launched my interest in deja vu. But I think the most important thing to to underline there is it's not deja vu.
我们认为，对于他和类似的患者，所有这些人都患有这种痴呆症模式，并且是老年人，而且这种情况非常非常罕见。他们都有这种持续的熟悉感。这些患者不仅不能将这种熟悉感拒绝为虚假和错误的，反而接受了它，然后对其进行加工、润色并添加细节等等。所以这些是非常有趣的案例，开启了我对既视感的兴趣。但我认为最重要的一点是，这不是既视感。
And I actually regret ever using the word deja vu. but that's how everybody describes it. The carers and the doctors involved, they all say, this guy's got permanent deja vu. And then you asked about epilepsy. Epilepsy, my interest in epilepsy came a bit afterwards. The only kind of scientific studies of deja vu
我实际上很后悔使用“既视感”这个词。但每个人都这样描述它。相关的护理人员和医生都说，这个人有永久性的既视感。然后你问到了癫痫。我对癫痫的兴趣是在那之后才产生的。既视感的唯一科学研究
for maybe 100 years were within the domain of the study of epilepsy. So it's long been known that certain people, not everybody, certain people with epilepsy reports Dejave, which is associated with seizure activity. So before or maybe just during seizure activity. And as a result, if we wanted to research DejaVue, they seem like a very helpful group of people to help us better understand what's going on. Certainly for some people with epilepsy, Deja vu is clinically relevant because it can signal that they're about to have a seizure, which is something they need to know about. But also, for us wanting to better understand Deja vu, with those people, at least,
可能在 100 年里都是在癫痫研究领域内进行的。所以人们早就知道，某些人，不是所有人，某些患有癫痫的人会报告既视感，这与癫痫发作活动有关。所以在癫痫发作活动之前或期间。因此，如果我们想研究既视感，他们似乎是一个非常有帮助的群体，可以帮助我们更好地了解正在发生的事情。当然，对于一些癫痫患者来说，既视感在临床上是相关的，因为它可以预示他们即将癫痫发作，这是他们需要知道的事情。但同时，对于我们想要更好地了解既视感的人来说，至少在这些人身上，
Deja Vu appears to be more frequent and more predictable, so that helps us get a handle on what's going on in Dejaou. And unlike the patients with dementia, we do believe, that there's no difference between the deja vu experience by people with and without epilepsy. It's a very similar kind of thing, except you might imagine that in epilepsy, it's due to neuronal communication and electrical activity, which is in some way disrupted. But that's not the same case for us necessarily, although that's a story where we need more research. Make every get-together chill. This Memorial Day, get up to an extra $1,000 off select top brand appliances like LG.
既视感似乎更频繁、更可预测，这有助于我们掌握既视感中正在发生的事情。与痴呆症患者不同，我们确实认为，患有和未患有癫痫的人所经历的既视感之间没有区别。这是一种非常相似的事情，只是你可以想象在癫痫中，这是由于神经元通讯和电活动在某种程度上受到了干扰。但这对于我们来说不一定是一样的情况，尽管这是一个我们需要更多研究的故事。让每一次聚会都轻松惬意。这个阵亡将士纪念日，购买 LG 等顶级品牌家电，最高可享 1,000 美元额外优惠。
Plus, get free delivery at the Home Depot. Tackle pool towels and camp laundry with a large capacity washer. And host and style with the fridge-serving craft ice, mini-craft ice, cube ice, and crushed ice. Shop appliance savings now through June 3rd at the Home Depot. Offer valid May 14th through June 3rd, U.S. only. Free delivery on appliance purchases of $998 or more. See Store Online for DT. Now, there is sort of the opposite of deja vu, right, which is called Jaumevo.
此外，在家得宝（The Home Depot）享受免费送货服务。用大容量洗衣机处理泳池毛巾和露营衣物。用带有制冰功能的冰箱招待客人，提供工艺冰块、迷你工艺冰块、方冰和碎冰。即日起至 6 月 3 日，在家得宝选购家电优惠。优惠有效期为 5 月 14 日至 6 月 3 日，仅限美国。购买 998 美元或以上的家电可享免费送货。详情请见店内或在线说明。现在，有一种类似于既视感的对立面，对吧，叫做“未视感”（Jamais vu）。
That's something that you've never experienced. Can you tell us a little bit more about what that is? The term, I believe, is not that widely known, but people recognize the sensation. Yeah, so exactly. When we do questionnaires on Jaievoo, we have to help people understand what it is we're trying to talk about. and happily people do understand and identify this experience. So Jamivu happens in daily life most frequently for things like spelling and using words.
那是你从未经历过的事情。你能告诉我们更多关于那是什么吗？我相信这个术语并不广为人知，但人们能认出这种感觉。是的，完全正确。当我们对未视感进行问卷调查时，我们必须帮助人们理解我们试图谈论的是什么。幸运的是，人们确实理解并认同这种体验。所以未视感在日常生活中最常发生在拼写和使用单词等方面。
So you may have had this experience. I definitely have had it where you're using a word and all of a sudden, even though you know the word is spelled right and you've produced it correctly, there's something wrong. It feels it feels like it's not right. So once I had it for the word this, I was using the word this. And all of a sudden it was like, well, this isn't how it's spelled. This can't be right.
所以你可能经历过这种情况。我绝对经历过，当你使用一个单词时，突然之间，即使你知道这个单词拼写正确，并且你已经正确地写出来了，但有些地方不对劲。它感觉，它感觉不对。所以有一次我用“this”这个词时，我正在使用这个词。突然之间，感觉就像，嗯，这不是它的拼写方式。这不可能是对的。
It seems pretty common for words. At least that seems to be the most common version. But when I talk to people about it, and again, I'll talk about my own experience and hope that I'm not the only person to have had such things, I once had it quite profoundly looking at my father's face. And it was like, wow, this is, it was like I knew it was my father. There was no way in which I didn't recognize him. But I was looking at him thinking, well, that's, that's really, there's something strange about this.
对于单词来说，这似乎很常见。至少这似乎是最常见的版本。但当我与人们谈论它时，我再次谈谈我自己的经历，希望我不是唯一一个有这种经历的人，我曾经在看着我父亲的脸时，非常深刻地经历过它。感觉就像，哇，这是，感觉就像我知道那是我父亲。我没有任何理由不认出他。但我看着他心想，嗯，那，那真的，这有什么奇怪的地方。
It's a strange kind of idea that that is my, that is my father. And it's almost like you see your father's face with fresh eyes. You come to something fresh. And you have this kind of sense of novelty, like you're seeing something for the first time, even though you know it's your father. And there's no, there's no question that you wouldn't recognize him. It's more like the recognition seems strange in some way. So in JamiVu, just like with Dejavu, they are opposites,
这是一种奇怪的想法，那是我，那是我父亲。这几乎就像你用全新的眼光看你父亲的脸。你以一种新鲜的方式看待某事。你有一种新奇感，就像你第一次看到某事一样，即使你知道那是你父亲。而且毫无疑问，你不会认不出他。这更像是这种识别在某种程度上显得很奇怪。所以在未视感中，就像既视感一样，它们是相反的，
but the key experience is this experience of strangeness and a conflict between two evaluations. So the conflict in Dejaou is that you know it's new. It's something you've never talked about before or a place you've never been before, but somehow it's. feels like it's familiar. And then you have the opposite with the opposite being that you know very well that this is a word that you've used and you can write it perfectly well. But somehow it looks strange or it looks wrong or you have to double check what you're doing.
但关键体验是这种陌生感以及两种评估之间的冲突。所以既视感的冲突在于你知道它是新的。这是你从未谈论过的事情，或者是一个你从未去过的地方，但不知何故，它感觉很熟悉。然后你有了相反的情况，相反的情况是你非常清楚这是一个你使用过的单词，并且你可以写得非常完美。但不知何故，它看起来很奇怪，或者看起来不对，或者你必须仔细检查你在做什么。
And exactly the same with people's faces. And it goes on, Akira O'Connor, who's my main partner in crime with this research work that we do together. He says he's had a Jemé Mvue for driving to the extent that he, you know, was really unsure of what he was doing and what pedal was doing what in the car. Wow. It's a little scary. It is a little scary. Well, he pulled over. He's a sensible chap.
对于人的脸也是如此。而且还在继续，Akira O'Connor，他是我们一起进行这项研究的主要搭档。他说他曾有过一次开车时的未视感，以至于他真的不确定自己在做什么，车里的哪个踏板在起什么作用。哇。这有点可怕。确实有点可怕。嗯，他靠边停车了。他是个明智的人。
But when those things happen, they're very, very rare. But again, that's another kind of piece of evidence as to what's happening in Jamevue. because driving is a very fluent automatic behavior. And we find in the lab the easiest way to generate Jemavu is by another very fluent automatic behavior, which is writing. And we ask people to repeatedly write the same word until they feel pretty strange about the word.
但当这些事情发生时，它们非常非常罕见。但同样，这是关于未视感中正在发生的事情的另一种证据。因为驾驶是一种非常流利、自动的行为。我们在实验室中发现，产生未视感最简单的方法是通过另一种非常流利、自动的行为，即写作。我们要求人们反复写同一个单词，直到他们对这个单词感到非常奇怪。
And that's the work for which we won the Ig Nobel Prize because it's a pretty strange thing to do. And in fact, it's basically, when we designed the experiment, it was based on my experience of punishment at school where I had to write lines and write the same sentence over and over again. I will not talk in French class. I think it was, but I can't remember. And I realized that writing this sentence over and over again, I must have been about 12, really made me feel strange. And it wasn't an unpleasant sensation, but it was very strange. So, yeah, I guess nearly 20 years later I came to the idea, oh, that could be a cool way of, of invoking these strange sensations, these conflicts between familiarity and lack of familiarity. So you can instigate one, Ja me, but can you in a lab instigate Dejaveu?
这就是我们获得搞笑诺贝尔奖的研究，因为这是一件非常奇怪的事情。事实上，当我们设计这个实验时，它基本上是基于我在学校受惩罚的经历，当时我不得不写行，一遍又一遍地写同一个句子。我想是“我不会在法语课上说话”，但我记不清了。我意识到一遍又一遍地写这个句子，我当时大概 12 岁，真的让我感到很奇怪。那不是一种不愉快的体验，但非常奇怪。所以，是的，我想大概 20 年后我有了这个想法，哦，这可能是一种调用这些奇怪感觉、这些熟悉感和缺乏熟悉感之间冲突的酷方法。所以你可以引发一种未视感，但在实验室里你能引发既视感吗？
I mean, how do you study it since it's such a fleeting, subjective thing? Yeah, that's a good question. So the first thing is that Deja vu took a little bit of time to get going, as an experimental concern. And I think there's two reasons for that. The first reason is that subjective experiences kind of fell out of grace in psychology, but since the 1980s, we've been able to tackle
我的意思是，既然它是一种如此短暂、主观的事情，你如何研究它？是的，这是一个好问题。所以第一件事是，作为一项实验课题，既视感花了一点时间才开始。我认为有两个原因。第一个原因是主观体验在心理学中有点失宠，但自 20 世纪 80 年代以来，我们已经能够直接处理
subjective experiences head on. But that's kind of a historical note. The second issue is we were kind of waiting for a theoretical entity that might be useful to better understand. deja vu because it didn't seem easy to classify what deja vu was. In the title, it's deja vu. It's about vision. So we tend to think it's about what we see and perception. But in fact, the best theoretical entity is familiarity. So familiarity is supposed to be like a memory
主观体验。但这算是一个历史注脚。第二个问题是，我们一直在等待一个可能有助于更好地理解既视感的理论实体，因为它似乎不容易分类什么是既视感。在标题中，它是既视感（deja vu）。它是关于视觉的。所以我们倾向于认为它是关于我们所看到的和感知的。但事实上，最好的理论实体是熟悉感。所以熟悉感应该像是一种记忆
process, which we know quite a lot about. So you can have familiarity for concepts which may just feel like you know about them without really being able to retrieve too much about them. So the examples I like are things like when you're a child, you were very familiar with a concept, let's say, like a home computer. You had a home computer for five years and it was called an an acorn electron. And then 20, 30 years later in your life, you might encounter something like that acorn electron in a different concept. It's now the name of a rock group or something like that. And what you may find is familiarity. You may have this, wow, that rings some bells. That means something to me that concept. And so familiarity is kind of one of the cornerstones of how
过程，我们对此了解很多。所以你可以对概念有熟悉感，这可能只是感觉你知道它们，而不能真正检索到关于它们的太多信息。所以我喜欢的例子是，当你还是个孩子时，你对一个概念非常熟悉，比如说，像家用电脑。你有一台家用电脑五年了，它叫 Acorn Electron。然后 20、30 年后，你可能会在不同的概念中遇到像 Acorn Electron 这样的东西。它现在是一个摇滚乐队的名字之类的。你可能会发现的是熟悉感。你可能会有这种，“哇，那听起来很耳熟。”那个概念对我来说意味着什么。所以熟悉感是日常生活如何运作的基石之一。
memory works in daily life. And we think it operates like when you hear this acorn electron kind of idea, you're like, oh, okay, well, that's, that feels familiar to me. Well, what? and then you can coordinate your memory processes to try and research for things in memory. So given that you know that this entity familiarity exists, that's really what we can pin our DejaVue research on. And here, to cut a long story short, I think there's some really elegant experiments
我们认为它的运作方式就像当你听到这种 Acorn Electron 的想法时，你会觉得，哦，好吧，嗯，那，那对我来说感觉很熟悉。嗯，什么？然后你可以协调你的记忆过程，尝试在记忆中搜索事物。既然你知道这个实体“熟悉感”存在，那确实是我们可以在其上钉住我们的既视感研究的东西。在这里，长话短说，我认为有一些非常优雅的实验
which are done which kind of provoke DejaVu in the lab, and I can really praise these experiments and say how elegant and wonderful I think they are because in fact, I'm not responsible for any of them, but Anne Cleary, who's done a lot of research on deja vu, she's used, I think my favorite experiment of hers uses virtual reality. And what she does is she provokes this sense of familiarity by using similarity.
在实验室中引发了既视感，我可以真正称赞这些实验，并说我认为它们是多么优雅和美妙，因为事实上，我对此不负任何责任，但 Anne Cleary，她对既视感做了很多研究，她使用，我想我最喜欢她的实验是使用虚拟现实。她所做的是通过使用相似性来引发这种熟悉感。
And since the 19th century, one of the ideas about what causes deja vu is a similarity between something you've encountered previously in your life and something which you encounter now where you can't identify that source of familiarity. So in the daily life, you might go into your friend's flat for the first time, your friend's apartment for the first time. And the layout of the apartment is such that there's the window in front of you and the fireplace, the left of you and the sofa and the TV. And in fact, that configuration matches exactly something that you've already seen before in your life. You can't remember what it is.
自 19 世纪以来，关于既视感成因的想法之一是，你生活中之前遇到过的事物与你现在遇到但无法识别那种熟悉感来源的事物之间的相似性。所以在日常生活中，你可能会第一次走进朋友的公寓。公寓的布局是这样的，窗户在你前面，壁炉在你左边，沙发和电视。事实上，这种配置与你生活中已经见过的东西完全匹配。你不记得那是什么了。
But that's enough to provoke this sense of familiarity. So Anne Cleary, she's looked at that in virtual reality because it's quite easy to set up those kinds of things in experimental situations. And like that, she can provoke feelings of deja vu, and people report freely that they've had deja vu or something like it generated in her experiments. So that's really neat. And then she's taken that in lots of other different directions.
但这足以引发这种熟悉感。所以 Anne Cleary，她在虚拟现实中研究了这一点，因为在实验情况下设置这些东西很容易。像那样，她可以引发既视感，人们自由地报告说他们在她的实验中产生了既视感或类似的东西。所以这真的很棒。然后她又把这一点带向了许多其他不同的方向。
And then the other series of experiments, which is similar, are run by Akira O'Connor. And he's used pretty much as similar technique, but with words. And his thing is all about generating the conflict, which is in deja vu. So he does this really neat thing. He asks people to learn lists of words, which is something we do. bread and butter, that's what I'm paid to do mostly. He gets people to learn a list of words, and for each word they have to learn, they have to note down the first letter of the word. So they're doing something at the same time as looking at the word, and he keeps the note of that,
然后另一系列实验，也是类似的，是由 Akira O'Connor 运行的。他使用了几乎相似的技术，但用的是单词。他的重点是产生既视感中固有的冲突。所以他做了这件非常巧妙的事情。他要求人们学习单词列表，这是我们做的事情。面包和黄油，这就是我主要拿钱做的事情。他让人们学习一个单词列表，对于他们必须学习的每个单词，他们必须记下单词的第一个字母。所以他们在看单词的同时也在做某事，他保留了那个记录，
and he uses that with them later when he tests them. So there's this neat effect which we see often in memory experiments, which is if you learn a set of related information, it will give you a false memory and strong familiarity for something that you haven't learned. So if I give you a list of words to learn, which is like doze, rest, blanket, bed, snore, pillow, tired, etc. And then a bit later on I show you the word sleep. You'll think that you've seen the word sleep now. I didn't give you the word sleep. So that's like a kind of false memory paradigm.
并在他后来测试他们时使用它。所以有一个我们在记忆实验中经常看到的巧妙效果，即如果你学习一组相关信息，它会给你带来虚假记忆和对你没有学习过的东西的强烈熟悉感。所以如果我给你一个单词列表让你学习，比如“打盹、休息、毯子、床、打鼾、枕头、疲倦”等等。然后过一会儿我给你看“睡觉”这个词。你会认为你现在看到了“睡觉”这个词。我没有给你“睡觉”这个词。所以这就像一种虚假记忆范式。
but what you have for the word sleep is familiarity. So what Akira did, which is really novel, was he did that kind of experiment, which is fairly standard in the experimental psychology. But the new thing he did was to ask people to look at the numbers of words that started with a certain letter. So at the same time as presenting them with the word sleep, he also presented them with the information
但你对“睡觉”这个词有熟悉感。所以 Akira 所做的，非常新颖的是，他做了那种实验，这在实验心理学中相当标准。但他所做的新事情是要求人们查看以特定字母开头的单词数量。所以在他向他们展示“睡觉”这个词的同时，他还向他们展示了信息，
that no words that they actually saw on the list began with an S. So that is exactly like the conflict that's inherent in deja vu. And I think that's a really neat demonstration of really what's going on. It's like that. It's just like that. Well, sleep feels familiar. Yes, yes. I've encountered that before.
即他们在列表中实际看到的单词中没有一个是以 S 开头的。所以这完全就像既视感中固有的冲突。我认为这是一个非常巧妙的演示，展示了真正发生了什么。就像那样。就是那样。嗯，“睡觉”感觉很熟悉。是的，是的。我以前遇到过那个。
But hang on, it's impossible. And so people identify that as being like deja vu. So are there brain imaging studies that help you to understand what's going on in people's brains when they're having these experiences? Yeah. So that's a good question. In healthy subjects, Akira has done that work as well. So we know that when people are having something like a Dejavert experience, it's the prefrontal cortex which is activated.
但是等等，这不可能。所以人们将其识别为既视感。那么是否有脑成像研究可以帮助你了解人们在经历这些体验时大脑中发生了什么？是的。这是一个好问题。在健康受试者中，Akira 也做了那项工作。所以我们知道，当人们经历类似既视感的体验时，前额叶皮层被激活了。
And the prefrontal cortex is proposed to be involved in this kind of detection of conflict. And it's kind of a higher order system which kind of, watches what's going on beneath it, if you see what I mean. So it's there to control and coordinate what's happening in memory. So that's consistent with this kind of aspect, which is about detecting conflict and your relationship with your memory rather than memory itself. That's one kind of avenue of research. There's not a lot of neuroimaging research done on healthy populations.
前额叶皮层被提议参与这种冲突的检测。它是一种更高级的系统，它监视着它下面发生的事情，如果你明白我的意思的话。所以它在那里控制和协调记忆中发生的事情。所以这与这种关于检测冲突以及你与记忆的关系而不是记忆本身的方面是一致的。这是研究的一种途径。在健康人群中并没有进行太多的神经影像研究。
What there's more of is kind of, classic neuropsychology. So good old neuropsychology on on volunteers who are very keen to help us on research who have epilepsy, for instance, or even acquire brain injury. And those people with Dejave, we can converge on the fact that there's definitely implication of the temporal lobes and the areas which we know are responsible from memory. And The particular zone is the zone which is described as being para-hypochampal. So the hippocampus is what we teach as students in the first year of their undergraduate degrees that is the area which is responsible for memory.
更多的是一种经典的神经心理学。所以对那些非常热衷于帮助我们研究的志愿者进行良好的老式神经心理学研究，例如患有癫痫的人，甚至获得性脑损伤的人。对于那些有既视感的人，我们可以聚焦于这样一个事实，即绝对涉及颞叶和我们知道负责记忆的区域。特定的区域是被描述为海马旁区的区域。所以海马体是我们教导本科一年级学生它是负责记忆的区域。
But just outside that area in the brain, just connected to it is another zone, which is responsible for familiarity. So it's no surprise that this intense. sensation of familiarity is associated to activation in that area. And we've actually known that for quite a long time because of the studies of the pioneering studies in epilepsy, trying to understand different kinds of epileptic focus and the changes that people experience in daily life with those things. So there's kind of two zones that are involved.
但在大脑中该区域之外，与其相连的是另一个区域，它负责熟悉感。所以这种强烈的熟悉感与该区域的激活相关联也就不足为奇了。事实上，我们已经知道这一点很长时间了，因为癫痫的开创性研究试图了解不同类型的癫痫灶以及人们在日常生活中经历的这些事情的变化。所以涉及两个区域。
It would be the temporal lobes for this kind of familiarity part. and then the prefrontal cortex, which is in some way monitoring what's going on in the temple lobes. So we can imagine those two different zones are involved. It seems that there are a number of these types of experiences that you study that are all related. There's also Deja Rivay, for example, which has to do with dreaming. Yeah. Can you explain what some of these others are and how they're related? Yeah, well, I think, I mean, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's, there's,
对于这种熟悉感部分，它将是颞叶，然后是前额叶皮层，它以某种方式监测颞叶中发生的事情。所以我们可以想象这两个不同的区域都参与其中。似乎你研究的这些类型的体验中有很多是相关的。例如，还有“梦视感”（Deja Reve），它与做梦有关。是的。你能解释一下其中一些其他的是什么以及它们是如何相关的吗？是的，好吧，我想，我的意思是，有，有，有，有，有，
There's almost a jokey response to this in which I like to point out that some researchers in déjà vu have tried to discover, in quotation marks, there's many different forms of deja vu that exist as possible. And for me, certainly living in France, it seems like they're just running through their French past participates that they've learned. So you can imagine there's deja vu, déjà vu, déjà vu, déjà vu, deja vu, which is to have already dreamt. and we can go on and on. There's Deja Saint-I which is already felt. And some researchers who are not motivated by the same scientific concerns as me would identify really 20, 30 different types of Dejaue.
对此几乎有一个开玩笑的回答，我喜欢指出，一些既视感研究人员试图发现，加引号，尽可能多地存在不同形式的既视感。对我来说，当然住在法国，看起来他们只是在浏览他们学过的法语过去分词。所以你可以想象有既视感、梦视感、感视感，梦视感是已经梦到过。我们可以继续下去。有“感视感”（Deja Senti），即已经感觉到。一些不像我那样受科学关注驱动的研究人员会真正识别出 20、30 种不同类型的既视感。
Deja Reve is something which is beginning to gather scientific interest and we think it would be distinct from deja vu, and it's this sensation of having already dreamt something or experiencing something which feels to you like you'd already experienced it in a dream. In epileptic patients, it's a bit of a different concern, I think, because it seems that there might be kind of reactivation of material that was indeed experienced as part of a dream.
梦视感是开始引起科学兴趣的东西，我们认为它将与既视感不同，它是已经梦到过某事或经历某事的感觉，这让你觉得你已经在梦中经历过它。在癫痫患者中，我认为这是一个有点不同的问题，因为它似乎可能存在确实作为梦的一部分经历过的材料的重新激活。
I think with the people that I work with, when I talk about Deja Revei, I think, and I remember thinking this myself before I studied psychology, deja vu is pretty weird, and when you have it, you're trying to explain to yourself why it is that you find something familiar.
我想和我一起工作的人，当我谈论梦视感时，我想，我记得在学习心理学之前我自己也这样想，既视感非常奇怪，当你产生它时，你试图向自己解释为什么你觉得某事很熟悉。
And I think without wanting to kind of trick yourself, you nonetheless think that, well, a pretty good bet, is that I dreamt something like this, and now I'm encountering it again. And it seems to be like a natural interpretation of this sense of familiarity that you are now encountering something
而且我认为在不想欺骗自己的情况下，你仍然认为，嗯，一个相当不错的赌注是，我梦到过类似的东西，现在我再次遇到它。这似乎是对这种熟悉感的一种自然解读，即你现在正在遇到某事
that you already dreamt. And that's an idea that's entered into kind of popular thought because that was Jung's idea of what Deja Vu was. And Freud and Young both thought that there was kind of this aspect of the unconscious and the dream state, which was related to Dejaouille. I think we just need more research, but there's, I mean, there's data that shows that there's
你已经梦到过了。这是一个进入大众思想的想法，因为那是荣格关于既视感是什么的想法。弗洛伊德和荣格都认为存在这种潜意识和梦境状态的方面，这与既视感有关。我认为我们只需要更多的研究，但我的意思是，有数据表明
definitely something going on. People who remember their dreams are more likely to have deja vu. And that's the finding that's been replicated for in across different research labs and in different studies. So there seems to be something going on with dreaming. And I'm, I'm not quite prepared to say what that is yet, but it's certainly something very interesting. And then for the other types of deja vu, I try not to proliferate the different types of deja vu. I think my job is to generate plausible accounts of deja vu based on the memory systems. And I think there might be a weaker form which is more about familiarity and a stronger
绝对有事情在发生。记得自己梦境的人更有可能产生既视感。这是在不同研究实验室和不同研究中被复制的发现。所以梦境似乎确实发生了一些事情。我还没有准备好说那是什么，但这绝对是非常有趣的事情。对于其他类型的既视感，我尽量不增加既视感的不同类型。我认为我的工作是基于记忆系统生成既视感的合理说明。我认为可能有一种更弱的形式，更多的是关于熟悉感，而一种更强
form which is more about really believing that you can remember something, which might give you the feeling that you're about to predict what's about to happen. next. So not everybody, we think in our question is about 20% of the time. When you have deja vu, you also have the feeling that you can predict what's going to happen next. I think we need to start looking at that aspect of things as well, because that might be a stronger, different form of deja vu than the form where you just have a vague sensation of familiarity. People who regularly listen to this podcast probably know that I have a particular fascination with odd psychological syndromes. And there is another one that is, you know, that is a particular
的形式，更多的是关于真正相信你可以记住某事，这可能会给你一种你即将预测接下来会发生什么的感觉。所以不是每个人，我们认为在我们的问卷中大约 20% 的时间。当你产生既视感时，你也会有你可以预测接下来会发生什么的感觉。我认为我们需要开始研究事情的那个方面，因为那可能是一种比你只有模糊的熟悉感的既视感更强、不同的形式。经常听这个播客的人可能知道我对奇怪的心理综合症有特别的迷恋。还有另一个，你知道，这是一个特别的
that is, it sounds like it might be related to Jaumevo, which is Capgras syndrome where people don't recognize their own loved ones. I think that they are strangers. Is this an extreme version of Jaumevo or is it something else totally? I am very pleased you ask that because I think that's, I think that's possible. I think that's one way of looking at it. And I think you and I share the same kind of passions for psychology because I think having worked with all kinds of people with all kinds of psychological and cognitive difficulties, I really believe that there's nothing that unusual that you can experience in terms of like psychological disturbance, like in Capgras, which doesn't have an equivalent in our own daily lives. I think it's more severe and more
也就是说，这听起来可能与“旧事如新症”（Jamais vu）有关，就像卡普格拉综合征（Capgras syndrome）一样，患者无法认出自己的亲人，认为他们是陌生人。这是“旧事如新症”的极端版本，还是完全不同的东西？我很高兴你问这个问题，因为我认为这是可能的。我认为这是一种看待它的方式。而且我认为你和我对心理学有着同样的热情，因为在与各种有心理和认知困难的人打交道后，我真的相信，在心理障碍方面，你所经历的任何不寻常的事情，在我们的日常生活中都有对应。我认为它只是更严重、更
problematic and debilitating. But yeah, I mean, I think the Jaemé vu thing, we can give people with faces. You do it with famous faces and you can just saturate the face so people just have to repeatedly look at the same face. And eventually it will begin to feel a bit different. So we know that inducing Ja'Mevue is all about this kind of idea of repetition of things that are very automatic.
更成问题且更令人衰弱。但是的，我的意思是，关于“旧事如新症”，我们可以给人们看人脸。你可以用名人脸来做实验，让人们反复观看同一张脸，最终这种感觉会开始变得有点不同。所以我们知道，诱发“旧事如新症”的关键在于这种对非常自动化的事物的重复。
And indeed, our research goal was to try and understand the link between Jaieu and that sensation that okay it looks real but it's not real I mean that sounds exactly like Capua's delusion that you do you know it's you or in fact it's not
事实上，我们的研究目标是试图理解“旧事如新症”与那种“看起来是真的，但实际上不是真的”的感觉之间的联系。我的意思是，这听起来完全像是卡普格拉妄想症，你知道那是他，但实际上却不是，
so much that you know you accept that person as being as looking like your husband but you you don't want you don't feel that that's your husband so that's it's almost
并不是说你接受那个人看起来像你丈夫，而是你不想、你感觉不到那是你丈夫，所以这几乎
exactly the same thing. It's the difference between a perception, which is a perception of a face that looks like my husband, and then the internal feeling which LaBelle, it doesn't feel like my husband. It's not right. It's something that's not right. So, yeah, it's definitely something we'd like to work more on. But if I don't get to do work and to elucidate, like, or concretely what the relationship between those two things is, I think it's important for this story. that we are all of us, each of us, living a kind of relationship with our perceptual systems and our cognitive systems. And when DejaVu and Jemivu happened, they're a little reminder of the fact that it doesn't
是一模一样的。区别在于感知——感知到一张看起来像我丈夫的脸，以及内在的感觉——它感觉不像我丈夫。这不对劲。有些事情不对劲。所以，是的，这绝对是我们想深入研究的课题。但如果我没能去研究并具体阐明这两者之间的关系，我认为这对这个故事很重要，那就是我们每个人都在与自己的感知系统和认知系统建立一种关系。当“既视感”（Déjà vu）和“旧事如新症”发生时，它们提醒我们，它并不
always run that smoothly. We are sometimes mistaken. And the reason why DejaVu is so interesting is because it's infrequent and it's rare, but it feels really, really weird. And if you imagine being stuck with sensations like that, which you can't reason with that you can't reject or that you can't justify, then I think you have a little window into how it is to be living with something like Capcarus dilution. And I think that's a very important point for psychology. So what are you researching right now? What are the big questions you want to answer?
总是运行得那么顺畅。我们有时会犯错。而“既视感”之所以如此有趣，是因为它不频繁且罕见，但感觉非常非常奇怪。如果你想象自己被这样的感觉困住，无法用理性去反驳，也无法去证明其合理性，那么我认为你就有了一个小窗口，可以了解患有卡普格拉妄想症是什么感觉。我认为这对心理学来说是一个非常重要的观点。那么你现在正在研究什么？你想回答哪些重大问题？
So right now I've got a really nice. project which we are looking to get funded, which is looking at deja vu in children, because it seems like nobody's done much direct asking of children about their experiences of deja vu. It's more retrospective questionnaires. And it seems like the scientific literature says you don't get deja vu until you're about 10 years old. And that's again a nice bit of data to try and understand what deja vu is. And we're working on the idea that deja vu is metacognitive. And as I say, it's a sign that you're able to kind of reflect upon your memory
目前我有一个非常好的项目，我们正在寻求资金支持，即研究儿童的“既视感”，因为似乎没有人直接询问过儿童关于他们“既视感”的经历。这更多是回顾性的问卷调查。科学文献似乎表明，你在10岁左右之前不会有“既视感”。这又是一个很好的数据点，可以用来尝试理解什么是“既视感”。我们正在研究“既视感”是元认知的观点。正如我所说，这是你能够反思自己记忆的一种迹象，
and maybe not be overly trusting of your memory. So we'd say it was a good thing. So the research that we've got ongoing is simply to look at when people get deja vu. We've got some interesting preliminary findings which look like deja vu. runs in families, not because it's genetic. I don't think I'm going to get a prize for finding out that deja vu is genetic. I think that's relatively unlikely. I think the simple explanation is there are people that talk about their experiences
也许不会过度信任你的记忆。所以我们会说这是一件好事。因此，我们正在进行的研究只是为了观察人们何时会出现“既视感”。我们有一些有趣的初步发现，看起来“既视感”在家族中遗传，但这并不是因为它是基因决定的。我不认为我会因为发现“既视感”是基因决定的而获奖。我认为这相对不太可能。我认为简单的解释是，有些人会谈论他们的经历，
and have a label to give to those experiences. And there are people, families that don't so much talk about those things. But certainly it runs in families. The more the parents have it, the more the children have it. That's pretty nice. and what we would ultimately like to do is to do kind of standard tests of metacognitive abilities and thinking skills and see if according to our prediction people who had deja vu or people who had deja vu earlier, children, they would be more metacognitively aware of other kinds of cognitive systems and how their memory works and things like that.
并给这些经历贴上标签。而有些家庭则不太谈论这些事情。但可以肯定的是，它确实在家族中存在。父母经历得越多，孩子经历得也就越多。这很不错。我们最终想做的是进行元认知能力和思维技能的标准测试，看看是否如我们预测的那样，那些有“既视感”的人，或者更早有“既视感”的儿童，会对其他类型的认知系统以及他们的记忆如何运作等方面有更强的元认知意识。
We're kind of really pushing this angle that deja vu is fact-checking, that it's something good and it's something useful. So one project would be to look at that. And then you can imagine it would just be helpful to start talking to children about, not just deja vu and jaie-vous also, but the tip of the tongue experience. These are all kind of metacognitive experiences, which are relationships with your own memory and your own cognitive systems. And I think if teachers and educators are talking about those kinds of things, it's going to help children in general with their learning and education and things like that. And then I think the second big project that we've got going on that we're just going to start is, I don't believe that these things are just quirks.
我们确实在极力推崇“既视感”是事实核查这一观点，即它是一件好事，也是一件有用的事。所以一个项目是研究这个。你可以想象，开始与孩子们谈论不仅仅是“既视感”和“旧事如新症”，还有“话到嘴边”的体验，这会很有帮助。这些都是元认知体验，是你与自己的记忆和认知系统之间的关系。我认为如果教师和教育工作者谈论这些事情，将有助于孩子们的一般学习和教育。我认为我们正在进行的第二个大项目，也是我们刚要开始的项目是，我不相信这些只是怪癖。
I don't think they're just random events which are meaningless. I think they are infrequent and they speak to their kind of complexity and sensitive. of the human cognitive system. And I think now we have smartphone technology and things like that, we could be much better at collecting examples and frequency of these experiences. And I think that those might be clinically useful. And my experience of working with deja vu is that people don't much do research on it, partly because nobody much asks people about their experiences of those things.
我不认为它们只是毫无意义的随机事件。我认为它们并不频繁，它们反映了人类认知系统的复杂性和敏感性。我认为现在我们有了智能手机技术等，我们可以更好地收集这些经历的案例和频率。我认为这些在临床上可能是有用的。我研究“既视感”的经验是，人们不太对其进行研究，部分原因是没人怎么询问人们关于这些事情的经历。
And I think we could be asking much more about people's subjective experiences in daily life with a hope to better understanding psychological distress, but also just the rich range of human experience. So with neurologists, I'm hoping to have like a very broad spectrum of all these kinds of subjective experiences and see how frequently they occur and what they mean to people. This is all really fascinating. I want to thank you for joining me. It's been real interesting talking to you. Thank you very much. Thank you very much for having me. It's been a pleasure for me, too. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeckycology.org
我认为我们可以更多地询问人们在日常生活中的主观体验，希望能更好地理解心理困扰，以及人类体验的丰富范围。因此，我希望与神经学家合作，获得所有这些主观体验的广泛光谱，看看它们发生的频率以及对人们意味着什么。这真的非常迷人。我想感谢你加入我的节目。和你交谈非常有趣。非常感谢。非常感谢你邀请我。对我来说也是一种荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email, us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方收听。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。本期《心理学谈话》由 Lee Winerman 制作。我们的音效编辑是 Chris Condihan。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。